one of the highly talented members of
the highly talented group of good
morning football right here to kick off
our number three Rich Eisen show in New
York it's Kyle Brant everybody get to
see you sir
rich I am thrilled to be here but what
am I doing here
what do you mean what are you doing here
Michael Irvin that's true Barry Sanders
correct Kurt Warner right and the guy
that makes Schrager giggle in the
morning was on Days of Our Lives a guy
real world
he's an 11 of real world let me I have
told you this before yes he also fallen
under the what am I doing here this show
has the best guests day in day out
it is a cavalcade of movie stars who
dropped out for me to get the spot was
it Daniel day-lewis Daniel day-lewis no
actually his right foot is the only only
he talks about his left his left one
that's the famous foot oh this is
awesome you need to drop out I reached
out to you a few days you did and I want
to fan out on you rich okay I went on
Dan Patrick show about a year ago and I
wanted to fan out on him I didn't get to
do it Dan whoo Dan Patrick I think it
was in the same spot I want to fan out
on that was my Jerry Jones invitation so
Dan who um I've watched a lot of you
rich okay early 2000s a lot of ESPN a
lot of SportsCenter yes I've always
loved what you do I love it this is very
cool for me to be here talking to very
cool and I think you have if I may yes I
think you have one of the truly
underappreciated this is SportsCenter
commercials okay which one is that I
think it is the one where you get sent
down to the mind
all right all the time and you're
sitting there and it's during high
school announcements and dance Aaron we
had to send rich down right and the
woman at the girl sitting next to you
can she goes take it away Richie go
Thank You Courtney
let's see that James Cape Oak pride and
all JV wrestlers turn on your uniforms
to coach by the end of the week it's
great I know everyone and the girl turns
because if you go to the school I don't
think even go to this school it's great
fun back story tell me it's funny that
you mentioned Dan Patrick okay because
that was about like year two year three
for me it's SportsCenter and I it was
very so I was very sensitive to the fact
that I was the one chosen to be sent
down
area okay I'm being very honest I told a
very honest story the other day about a
SportsCenter commercial would not let me
wash my hands coming out of the bathroom
and I was this one I was particularly
sensitive because I worked my ass off to
attain what I thought a certain level of
SportsCenter and there were others who
had been hired after me why am I the one
being sent down to high school and Dan
pulled me aside was this a get over it
essentially I mean that was his message
was get over it this is a funny
commercial get over it you know did you
have thoughts on who all should have
been sent pretty much name anybody
including our first our guest tomorrow
in my Greenberg he was they should be
sent down to the minors but you got the
good roll the Ritz you had the good
lines well I got a great lines you know
where they where they they asked me to
buy him beer yeah you know all of that
stuff and we shot it in an actual high
school and it was tough for me to go
through it but I I gutted it out and
it's now one of your favorite sports
Seneca but Dan literally was just like
pulled me aside like what's the matter
with this great suck it up exactly did
you feel the same way about the role
when you interrupted the broadcast with
the Williams sisters beads when you were
behind camera do you remember that one -
yes because I have encyclopedic
knowledge of the sports going on right
and I'm not sure I think it's Dan as
somebody else and there's all this noise
offset and you're getting your hair
beaded the Williams sisters in an
interrupts thought I had to do that
commercial it's also good one if the
Williams sisters wanted to reboot sure
point out a sequel wouldn't be able to
do it sorry I want rich know I'd
forgotten about that one it's a good one
it's not fun well in in the green room
of our show back in Los Angeles and do
in because I've had this on the back of
a chair of any place I've ever you know
had an office since then is the kid
Eisen
shirt or that that was that Lou Duva war
hmm and the sports the robe the the silk
you know the corner man silk that Lou
Duva wore in the the Sports Center
commercial where you know they came in
during the commercial break and I cut
the prompter you know you know cut me
Lou
cut me and I I did ad lib you you know
spitting out with my pinky extended and
the funny thing is when you watch that
commercial is they bleep out Lou Duva
the famous corner man because they had
to they could not find three to four
continuous safe for work seconds to
actually edited the commercial because
he was acting himself and he would curse
up a blue streaks they had to bleep him
out for the commercial so he took off
the silk and I remember they they just
left it on on the side and I'm like can
I have that the lecture so I've had it
to this day I eat this up this behind
the music of these SportsCenter
commercials when they would come to you
guys with an idea like right was it was
it really kind of antsy about who gets
to be in in who got it must be a Kyle
Brent the helmet they they they would
come up with a campaign yeah we would
hear that the commercial campaign was
coming and we all didn't say a word but
all Sports Center anchors are you are
you doing it one of the spots like yeah
and then Dan would eventually say yeah
I'm doing like three or four just drop
it share it
knowing that what's what sort of ripple
in our pond that would leave you know
compare notes like who's in what how
many lines do you have and then the
people from ESPN who are part of the
Wyden and Kennedy ad agency they would
have like this big loose-leaf booklet of
all the scripts of them the ten spots
that we have and they would literally
hold it up like that like a like a like
a poker hand to their chest to make sure
nobody could crazy the cards there's
like handcuffed to their wrists I was
really just like Sogo is one spot that
Stewart and I ad-lib okay totally ad-lib
and it was when they came up and they
were shooting commercials like around
November and we asked them like how come
there's never been like a holiday themed
Sports Center commercial campaign
they're like
and we just never really thought of it
we're like well we have an idea for one
beautiful and we you know had an idea
for one and they're like is there a
script we're like no we'll just do it
and we're like roll the cameras and we
told him what the idea was it I was at
my cubicle which was my real workspace
Stewart would come up to me because he
had an office I'm at my workspace typing
away on a script and he would come up to
me and present to me a holiday gift okay
and I opened it up and it was my AFB my
earpiece and I put it in and I it fit me
in everything how'd you know you're less
is what I said to my how did you know it
I mean just like you know just cuz
essentially what the what it was and
then we would look at each other we did
this looked at each other paused gave
this quick bro hug and then backed off
happy you know happy holidays beautiful
and he walked away one take done and I
would I've seen it on the air once and I
have not seen it again I would love to
see that spot I feel terrible I don't
remember this one I thought I knew them
all I'm telling you they they air it
hardly aired it not on YouTube I don't
think I don't think so it's just you
could look it up rich do sports and
Christmas
they even had like did a little jingle
in the back and the date at the bottom
looked like it was around Christmas you
always date yeah you guys were full
producers on that we I mean they didn't
even have it in their little script that
they're holding to they're just it makes
me one or the other
yes fan guys were like oh great now like
Eisen and Scott or come up there all the
time
they're breaking the rules yeah we just
came over their own one all day I love
that stuff well great look I appreciate
you bringing that over this to be about
you and I want to know and everybody is
fanning out on Good Morning football I
mean what I say that at some point I
knew there had to be you know another
live tentpole tune in everybody's
watching and last year at in London uh
it was me and Irv and we met with the
Jacksonville brass before the game that
we were calling yeah and the Jaguar
players would come in walk right past me
and Irv and everybody else went right up
to Peter
everybody eggs no no but it was the show
that was it yeah cuz the job these it is
now it is on television sets in every
locker room and now there's no question
about it don't know so what you were
doing in your first few months where you
just figured you just throw stuff
against the wall and nobody's seeing it
anyway yeah sure no now we get crazy
sometimes that the nickname for the show
is total excess like because we go
because we go wild because it is
excessive and it is we get these screen
caps sometimes from inside the
facilities yes and you start to think
wow so Richard Sherman is really sitting
there watching that and we just had a
second with it was sort of critical of
Richard Sherman a little bit it makes
you feel about that big but then I don't
know what am I supposed to do not do it
it's I just don't it I think players if
it they feel it is fair yeah and if you
are having fun and not making fun
I think players absolutely can handle it
I didn't know there's no doubt about it
certainly if they know that the core of
it is a love of the game and that what
you're doing is not just for the sake of
having fun at their expense
yeah I think players will absolutely I
think so Cris Collinsworth came on the
show once and he said I like what you
guys do because football should be fun
and that kind of became our de facto
motto football should be fun right it is
because it gets real heavy sometimes
especially these days but we try that on
every day every segment well I mean Karl
Brandt here on the Rich Eisen show when
we did start the NFL Network everyone
was calling it the no fun league and a
lot of people might still do that right
now I understand but you know the idea
was to have fun right from the get-go
and the commercial campaigns you talk
about sports and it was the same people
with you know Steve Bornstein who
launched the NFL Network from ESPN
brought in Judy fearing who was behind a
lot of the Sports Center commercials she
was the one who came up with the big man
dance challenge commercial okay at the
start of the earth all network we also
you know had the NFL Total Access spots
with dear mr. fantasy playing in the
background
what about it's good to be rich that's
what was that one you induced McAllister
looking at watches I mean that's a great
shot that would have frozen mon on time
that's a great you through a loop and
looked at images my head
yeah like I agreed with with the bling
he was buying this giant cable-knit
sweater on its baggy as hell it's so 15
years ago and this watch just looks
gaudy as all get-out but you're looking
in your yeah deuce that's it I'm like
that's a cool cold tub that's with Chris
Samuels of Washington yeah and and that
was a real cold tub my favorite one that
I gave I gave my my own wrinkle too
similar to extending the pinky for for
that SportsCenter one was looking under
the hood fur for you know for a replay
sure yeah and the the script called for
me to like give a thumbs up to the ref
yeah I just pulled away and I just gave
them I can't help back this year
instant replay underneath oh and I'm
like what's that do it I have no idea
how do you think that's gonna work this
year I see I didn't like the fasteners
Ference thing just to me the bedrock of
that when you're at home and you're on
the couch and you're watching your team
did my players foot come down and green
or white we look at it oh it's white
he's out of bounds right its objectivity
it's just so cut and dry this passenger
first thing is nuts
I mean it really is and I hope it works
out I'm obviously rooting for it but I
kind of pulled his arm down but did it
affect the catch I think so it's just so
so murky it's not the second foot come
came down or it didn't it's like we're
doing greco-roman in slow motion and I'm
concerned about it I am yeah I'm I am
too because of the unintended
consequence in a way and and then you're
leaving after good morning for my own
good morning football tomorrow I'm fired
up and then you're heading off to call
more Bears games how's that been for you
man it's nuts they the Bears to Cal
Bears did a really cool thing last
summer they said alright last year they
had five preseason games because I
played the Hall of Fame game right and
they said this is a preseason game
number five I know you've never done
play-by-play at any level which I hadn't
but since it's the fifth preseason game
nevermind a traditional broadcasts we
almost want you to try to do a little
version of good morning for
make it like a podcast about the Bears
don't worry that its second and six and
Tyler breakthrough and complete just be
you I did it I got the plane down
somehow and they invited me back so I do
the last preseason game and now nobody
plays and so it's just me Jim Miller and
Dave Wannstedt chopping it up about the
Bears for three hours launch it's
incredible yeah once that's coming out
with me that ol mustache when it tells
that Thomas stories and get into it we
love it here on set it's got great
stories and I grew up in the Chicago
suburbs when he was head coach so I
remember it really really well so
that'll be tomorrow and our Thursday
night soldier field like the mansion of
my dreams it's an incredible thing yeah
watch that was the Bears coach when we
first came on the air in a minute and he
had some classic press conferences that
we kept on replaying over and over just
for giggles in between takes for total
access yeah I remember that he's
probably got some really great does and
you know he's just he had the mustache
before everyone was doing it now it's so
cool and ironic he always had it and
he's actually been in the headlines this
week right so I was thinking about this
oh my god well we're talking about no
we're talking about unforeseen
retirements yes and everyone's talking
and Calvin Johnson the Ricky Williams
one was nuts when when he was when once
that was coaching with Miami Dolphins
and I felt like it was 10 minutes before
the season ricky said I'm just done and
he had his convictions about the weed
and whatnot but like I want to hear once
that's take on that because that blew my
mind you know what it's funny I had we
we had junior sail on dolphins cam just
as this was breaking okay on Total
Access and and and and anybody out there
who's watching on NFL Network knows
exactly where I'm going with this one
okay and we we told him like look we
have to ask junior a Ricky Williams
roster
even though you know it's not good news
for the Dolphins and you know return to
the page you know the quintessential
we're only talking about the people who
are here today totally and they're like
fine he's ready for it so I asked the
question and he called me Rick in
response and called me Rick the rest of
the interview Rick eyes on the show I
liked it and we were we were wondering
if that was just his way of protesting
sure and I said I think if he was
protesting we to call me dick
that's good I mean like if you're gonna
mess up my name but he called me Rick
the entire time so I was Rick on the set
for a very long time anytime jr. sale
came up its Rick here's Rick that's
amazing I know because he definitely
called me rich two-strike thanks rich
and then he transferred to Rick that he
did it reminds me excuse me dick I'm
sorry rich will move he made available
to us
maybe jr. sigh Jose I was going deep
there I didn't think that he picked you
he did I got Rick I got rickrolled in
Hawaii have you ever been Rick at any
point of your life
it's kind of cool name not to my face it
feels so different than race watch it to
my face she was jr. sale to my face and
a jr. sale of all people asking about
Ricky Williams you know I know huge
contracts he was not happy about it
hey man this went really fast because it
was a lot of fun as always and I look
forward to returning the favor by coming
on good morning football tomorrow I'm
thrilled to have you
it's called call backs this call backs
everywhere
Peter Schrager Nate Burleson Kay Adams
every single weekday 7:00 a.m. Eastern
only on NFL Network at Kyle Brant on
Twitter least I'll Brant NFL on
Instagram for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV
for free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app